[Aplausos]
[Música]
tras décadas y décadas cientos de años
dormido el gigante chino por fin se ha
despertado
ah
durante las últimas cuatro décadas el
crecimiento económico alcanzó un ritmo
medio del en torno al 10 por ciento
anual a lo largo de todos estos años
china se transformó paso de ser una
sociedad rural de agricultores pobres a
un país industrial moderno con grandes
metrópolis el pib per cápita ajustado
por la inflación se multiplicó por 24 la
esperanza en medio de vida aumentó en
más de 10 años y más de 700 millones de
personas dejaron atrás la pobreza según
datos del banco mundial
y de hecho en 2020 el propio banco
mundial publicó nuevas estimaciones que
colocaban ya la economía china por
delante de la norteamericana cuando el
pib se ajusta por la diferencia de
precios y no no se trata sólo del banco
mundial las estimaciones del fondo
monetario internacional apuntan
exactamente en la misma dirección
incluso el coronavirus no se pareció
todo un ejemplo de éxito y superioridad
del modelo chino mientras que el
gobierno de sillín ping logró contener
rápidamente la pandemia y cerrar el 2020
con unos datos económicos bastante
buenos la realidad no sólo en estados
unidos sino en todo occidente fue muy
pero que muy diferente que os voy a
contar
pues bien el caso es que todos estos
cambios han hecho según las encuestas
realizadas que una gran mayoría de
personas en todo el mundo consideren que
china superará próximamente a los
mismísimos eeuu como la primera
superpotencia mundial lo cual no resulta
especialmente sorprendente pensadlo un
momento en el imaginario colectivo los
chinos lo hacen todo lo fabrican todo
prácticamente se están convirtiendo los
dueños de medio mundo y que queréis que
os diga aparentemente los datos parecen
claros china tiene un pib ajustado mayor
mayores niveles de inversión mayores
flujos comerciales y su crecimiento
económico también es más alto vamos que
ya se pueden preparar los yankees por
ser los chinos son incluso los segundos
mayores propietarios de deuda
norteamericana tras japón ahora bien un
momento echar el freno quiere decir todo
esto que estamos condenados a la
hegemonía china que con toda seguridad
el país de los tres reinos se convertirá
en la gran superpotencia del mundo que
los eeuu están acabados como primera
potencia económica y militar pues mucho
ojo amigos porque con china las cosas no
son siempre lo que parecen queridos
amigas de visión política que dicen
exactamente los datos atentos
por cierto un apunte habéis invertido en
bolsa alguna vez esta labor hoy cara o
barata porque la bolsa norteamericana no
deja de batir una y otra vez sus máximos
históricos estaremos acaso ante la madre
de todas las burbujas no os perdáis el
último vídeo de si lo hubiera sabido y
el nuevo canal de información financiera
de mutuactivos con el que participamos
os dejo el link en la descripción pero
dicho esto sigamos
[Música]
la economía del dragón
lo primero que podríamos decir es que
hay que con pinzas los datos
chinos porque podrían ser no del todo
fiables es algo de lo que ya os hemos
hablado en visual polític pero podéis
creerme sean más o menos exactos es el
menor de los problemas a la hora de
valorar la tesis de que china superará
pronto a los eeuu al fin y al cabo no sé
es innegable que durante los últimos 40
años el país ha experimentado un
crecimiento y un desarrollo gigantesco
respecto a esto creo que no hay ninguna
duda basta con echar un vistazo a sus
enormes rascacielos sus modernas
infraestructuras a la pujante clase
media oa las nuevas empresas chinas que
como alibaba ottensen están extendiendo
sus tentáculos por todo el mundo ahora
bien ésta no es ni mucho menos toda la
historia lo cierto es que los eeuu
siguen siendo mucho muchísimo más ricos
que chinas y lo que es más importante la
diferencia a lejos de reducirse se está
ampliando cada vez más y más espera para
esto un momento estás de broma que cada
vez hay más diferencias entre eeuu y
china pero no habíamos dicho que el pib
ajustado chino ya ha superado el de los
eeuu pues sí pero el problema amigos es
que el pib es un indicador bruto que no
mide bien los costes ni la generación de
riqueza ni tampoco el margen en que un
país tiene para convertirse en toda una
superpotencia queréis un ejemplo pues
fijaos
desde el año 2000 el porcentaje de
millonarios respecto al conjunto de la
población se ha incrementado en china en
apenas medio punto mientras que en los
eeuu el incremento ha sido diez veces
superior hoy por hoy casi el 9% de los
adultos estadounidenses tienen un
patrimonio neto superior al millón de
dólares de hecho según datos de credit
suisse la diferencia de riqueza entre
los norteamericanos los chinos se ha
ampliado desde el año 2011 en más de 12
billones de dólares
pero como es esto posible no es acaso
china la fábrica del mundo pues si el
problema amigos es que es una fábrica
muy ineficiente china produce mucho de
ahí que su pib sea tan alto pero también
lo hace con unos costes de producción
enormes es decir la economía china es
grande pero terriblemente ineficiente y
no no me refiero a los salarios sino al
consumo de inputs como por ejemplo la
energía el agua las materias primas o
incluso el número de trabajadores
necesarios para desempeñar una tarea
[Música]
además luego una parte muy importante de
la producción de china se consumen
satisfacer las necesidades básicas de
sus 1400 millones de habitantes y
también del propio gobierno y el
problema aquí es que el pib mide la
producción anual digamos en términos
brutos pero no mide bien los costes ni
el excedente que finalmente se convierte
en riqueza y ahí ahí es donde está
precisamente la trampa y también es lo
que explica que por ejemplo un país tan
pobre como la india tenga el quinto
mayor pib del mundo a pesar de que
apenas tiene recursos para actuar como
una superpotencia y la inmensa mayor
parte de su población es muy pero que
muy pobre conclusión cuidado con los
datos que utilizas pero no nos desviemos
[Música]
pero ya sé lo que estáis pensando como
de ineficiente es la economía china y
por qué demonios lo es tanto pues veréis
el crecimiento económico de china puede
explicarse casi por completo por el
crecimiento de los recursos productivos
me explico entre el 90 y el 97 por
ciento del crecimiento económico chino
ha estado vinculado a la incorporación
de más y más trabajadores y a la
inversión en capital físico en cambio lo
que se denomina como productividad total
de los factores apenas ha representado
entre el 3 y el 7 por ciento de toda la
expansión económica y os preguntaréis
por qué esto es tan importante pues
porque esta productividad es lo que
permite hacer más con menos fijaos
imaginaos que tenemos dos fábricas con
la misma producción pero en cambio la
primera tiene una máquina y un
trabajador mientras que la segunda tiene
dos trabajadores y dos máquinas
evidentemente la primera fábrica es
mucho más eficiente más productiva logra
hacer más con menos de tal forma que por
un lado requiere invertir menos capital
y por tanto acumular menos deuda y por
otro deja libres factores productivos
una máquina y un trabajador para poder
montar otros negocios
veis la diferencia pues eso es
exactamente lo que ocurre con el caso de
china como la productividad es muy baja
para mantener el crecimiento económico
el gobierno ha tenido que invertir
enormes cantidades de dinero lo que ha
multiplicado la deuda
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea entre los
años 2007 y 2017 la deuda no financiera
de china se multiplicó por 4 lo que
supone un incremento mayor que el de
cualquier otro país del mundo y de hecho
ya ha superado la media de las economías
avanzadas y es algo que explica
perfectamente titulares como
evergrande y el fin del modelo chino de
construir construir y construir valorado
en 41 mil millones de dólares en 2020 el
espectacular desmoronamiento del grupo
inmobiliario expone profundas grietas en
la estrategia de crecimiento de pekín y
no nos engañemos como esta tendencia no
se puede mantener permanentemente y
además la sobreinversión ha generado
pues un montón de excedentes de
producción por todas partes fábricas que
no se necesitan ciudades fantasma y
costes crecientes a lo largo de toda la
economía pensado por ejemplo en los
intereses el mayor gasto energético los
mayores salarios por la menor
disponibilidad de trabajadores etcétera
etcétera el crecimiento chino se ha
venido realizando durante los últimos
años y la cuestión es que a diferencia
de china y eeuu tiene una economía mucho
más eficiente y sus empresas se
posicionan entre las más competitivas de
todo el mundo y el resultado es que su
productividad por trabajador no sólo es
mucho más alta que en china sino que
además la diferencia es cada vez más y
más grande además por si fuera poco con
una cuarta parte de la población china
las costas de bienestar y seguridad
interna de eeuu son mucho más reducidos
por ejemplo en el caso chino con una
producción más pequeña tienen que
alimentar vestir y calentar más gente lo
que hace que el excedente de producción
esto es la acumulación de riqueza sea
mucho más reducida el resultado china
crece más pero eeuu se hace cada vez más
y más rico y evidentemente cuanto más
ricos ea pues más capacidades tendrás
para mantener tu estatus de
superpotencia aquí ahora ya las cosas os
parecen un poquito diferentes pues
esperad un momento porque no hemos hecho
más que empezar
según cálculos del banco mundial y de
naciones unidas- el capital humano esto
es la formación las habilidades la
experiencia supone más de la mitad de la
riqueza de la mayoría de países y hasta
el 80% de la riqueza de las naciones más
desarrolladas y este es precisamente uno
de los puntos fuertes de los eeuu
en china poco más del 10% de la mano de
obra tiene un título universitario
frente al 44 por ciento de la mano de
obra estadounidense además la calidad de
las universidades norteamericanas está
muy por delante lo que es normal porque
en china ni siquiera existe un acceso
libre a internet oa las investigaciones
científicas del resto del mundo así
mientras que en la clasificación del
center for world university rankings la
mejor universidad china aparece en el
puesto 58 los eeuu tienen 29 de las 50
mejores universidades del mundo y no el
resto de rankings no son muy diferentes
para colmo cada año china pierde cientos
de miles de trabajadores bien formados
que se marchan a trabajar al extranjero
entre ellos decenas de miles de
ingenieros científicos
inventores y emprendedores eeuu en
cambio recibe un millón de trabajadores
extranjeros cada año entre ellos miles
de científicos e ingenieros procedentes
de todo el mundo incluyendo en la propia
china
[Música]
ah
en otras palabras que los americanos
tienen mejor plantilla mejor cantera y
encima cada año que pasa aprovechan
mejor el mercado de fichajes en parte
esto es lo que explican los mayores
niveles de productividad eeuu se ha
especializado en gran medida en
productos de alto valor añadido y
tecnológicamente avanzados que son muy
pero que muy difíciles de replicar para
china
de hecho una cosa que no se cuenta es
que de cada dólar de producción china
exportada a eeuu 55 centavos
corresponden a componentes y servicios
producidos en los propios eeuu
luego la creciente intromisión de xi
jinping en las empresas privadas ahí
está sin ir más lejos la guerra desatada
contra las grandes corporaciones
tecnológicas privadas del país tampoco
ayuda a que la productividad pues
incremente en el futuro lo mismo ocurre
con la corrupción o las trabas que
impone el partido comunista a todos
aquellos emprendedores que no sean de la
cuerda y eso no es todo aún nos queda un
último problema la demografía china está
envejeciendo mucho más rápido que eeuu y
su población mayor de 65 años se
triplicará con creces de aquí a mediados
de siglo tal y como podéis ver la
evolución de los dos países es muy pero
que muy diferentes y nada tiene un
problema enorme con y su población se va
a contraer fuertemente durante las
próximas décadas y la mayor proporción
de personas con más de 65 años supone
que el país tendrá que de traer recursos
de su producción para poder atenderles
así que amigos amigas no por mucho que
no le gusta xi jinping no parece que el
poder económico de china vaya a superar
en las próximas décadas al de eeuu ni
tampoco que el país asiático vaya a
contar con los recursos suficientes como
para luchar por el primer puesto de la
superpotencia mundial son simple y
llanamente los datos los datos los datos
y no no se pueden cambiar pero ojo
porque no se trata sólo de la economía
algo muy parecido ocurre también con las
fuerzas armadas atentos
la espada del dragón
en un pasado vídeo os contamos como la
estrategia de china en lo respectivo a
su ejército pasa esencialmente por
convertirse en toda una gran potencia
regional porque de momento lo cierto es
que las diferencias a nivel global son
abismales por ejemplo el gasto militar
de los eeuu es aproximadamente tres
veces el de china sí es verdad que los
soldados chinos cobran mucho menos pero
también lo es que el ejército chino
tiene 12 millones de soldados más que el
de eeuu y el resultado es que las
fuerzas armadas chinas tienen que pagar
muchos más salarios muchos costes de
manutención y muchas más pensiones esto
supone una carga gigantesca para que os
hagáis una idea se calcula que desde el
2008 el aumento del coste de personal ha
devorado más de la mitad de los aumentos
del presupuesto militar chino o sea que
por mucho que haya crecido este
presupuesto al final en realidad no ha
sido tanto porque por supuesto hoy en
día el número de tropas no es ni mucho
menos sinónimo de capacidad militar más
bien todo lo contrario lo que cuenta es
tener un ejército bien equipado bien
entrenado y con buena logística y sabéis
que hay eeuu arrasa los números son tan
apabullantes que no merece la pena hacer
ninguna comparativa
y
por si fuera poco el ejército chino
tampoco tiene experiencia de combate y
sus entrenamientos son mucho más pobres
entre otras cosas porque las tropas
chinas destinan cerca del 20 por ciento
de su tiempo a estudiar la ideología
comunista del gobierno chino y asistir a
mítines políticos y aunque es verdad que
china está haciendo grandes avances en
tecnología militar hablaremos de ello
aquí en visual político próximamente la
distancia con eeuu aún es sideral para
colmo las fronteras de china suponen un
desgaste enorme para sus fuerzas armadas
porque pues porque no se lleva
particularmente bien con la mayoría de
sus vecinos lo que le obliga a tener una
buena parte de su ejército disperso por
todo el país en concreto el ejército
chino dedica casi la mitad de sus
fuerzas armadas al control de las
fronteras y la seguridad interna un
escenario totalmente diferente al de
eeuu cuyo ejército está construido casi
por completo para extender su fuerza por
todo el mundo
[Música]
y un último apunte los vecinos y los
aliados
si nada se ha convertido en la gran
potencia regional en asia-pacífico pero
su peso no es tan apabullante como
podríamos pensar a simple vista por
ejemplo la armada china es la más
poderosa de la región sí pero apenas
representa en torno al 30 por ciento del
tonelaje naval de la zona los esfuerzos
militares de corea del sur japón la
india taiwán australia vietnam entre
otros muchos países hacen que la
competición esté más reñida de lo que
parece sobre todo porque la mayoría de
estos países no sólo no son aliados de
china sino que lo son de eeuu de hecho
eeuu ha ido cerrando alianzas militares
con cada vez más y más países durante
las últimas décadas y en cuestiones
diplomáticas eeuu también lleva por
mucho la delantera amigos amigas el
futuro no está escrito y desde luego
china se ha convertido en toda una
superpotencia y en un país con una
influencia enorme pero lo cierto es que
hoy por hoy los datos sugieren que sigue
aún muy lejos de los eeuu y lo que es
aún más importante todo apunta a que las
diferencias no sólo no se están cerrando
sino que incluso pueden estar aumentando
lo siento por todos aquellos a los que
no os guste la hegemonía norteamericana
pero por capacidad económica y por
capacidad militar creo que podemos decir
sin recibo carlos que hay en eeuu para
rato pero llegados hasta aquí turno para
ti como crees que se desarrollará la
competición económica entre estas dos
potencias eres de los que creen que
china terminará sobrepasando a la
potencia norteamericana déjanos por aquí
abajo tus comentarios y abramos si os
parece de debate y ya sabéis no olvidéis
suscribiros aviso político aunque seáis
forofos de xi jinping muchas gracias una
vez más por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]